[Music]
transformational festivals
well
Vera they're very in Vogue these days
people are hungry
for transformation but what exactly
does transformation feel like what is
the lived experience if we had to break
it down
that people are after in these
transformational
festivals well people are basically
looking to have their jadedness violated
they're looking for experiences that
violate their expectations and
presuppositions they're looking to be
stopped in their track transformational
festivals are about giving people
salience we call this the economy of
experience the experience economy
there's a whole economy being forged
around the increasing psychic appetite
for entrainment for heightened presence
for a lived experience that returns a
virginal noticing to the sense8 world or
what Michael pollen calls a sense of
First Sight unencumbered by knowingness
you're alive and engaged and entrained
in a world you forgot was possible and
in a way you forgot was possible there's
a heightened aliveness you know a place
like burning man perhaps is the epitome
in the experience economy Eric Davis
described it as a demolition derby of
reality constructs colliding in a
parched void it's the juxtaposition the
intensity of juxtaposition in the barren
landscape with works of art to take your
breath away but also speak to you
everything is making a statement and
everything prompts you into a world of
contemplation and it's Willy Wonka and
Alice in Wonderland all at once meets
Blade Runner and it's like something
happens that you're just more present to
the adventure and the whole thing
unfolds on a bicycle which further hurls
you into the magical bike ride
psychedelic undertone of a child at play
exploring a new world and you've got
your buddies with you and it's like
where are we going and what's going to
happen and I'm so in this moment I'm So
Alive In This Moment
people feel more
connected more in the here and now in
the thralls of play and wonder and
entrainment and flow and you know daily
life for so many just pales in
comparison we go through the motions of
the everyday unengaged
not present
not wanting to be there
you know resigned to the futility of our
days board Restless
the Mental Health crisis of course stems
from this stuck in ruminative Loops it's
like we're not
we're not into this we're not in the
expanded presence the heightened
qualitative intensity of the lived
experience the felt reality of direct
experience which is not in it most of
the time and so we go to these
transformational festivals to Glow our
minds and come to our senses and return
to just a kind of aliveness we're just
talking about aliveness it's no great
Insight it's no great psychedelic
schizophrenic realization there's no
real manic geometry at the end of the
day we're just talking about presence
we're just talking about play we're just
talking about laughter we're just
talking about Joy we're just talking
about entrainment we're just talking
about being there and Loving It
ultimately that's what it's about man I
try to gift myself these states of
rapture and play in my ordinary life I
try to bring back some of those insights
some of those
protocols and procedures the way my
friend Jamie Dames describes them the
knobs and levers approach to tweaking
our own lived experience to bring more
play into it like drawing a Line in the
Sand and creating a theatrical space
where there can be play and there can be
wonder and you can be in the throngs of
The Burning Man all over again because
the burning man is a state of being a
place we can pay visitation to
what is that line from the never-ending
story make believe I'm everywhere hidden
in the lines there upon a rainbow is the
answer to the never-ending story
oh man
make believe I'm everywhere hidden in
the lines there upon the pages is the
answer to a Never Ending Story so in the
end friends that's what it's about
seeing if we can bring ourselves back to
life unleash the free and brave Reckless
gods that live inside of us lose
ourselves and find ourselves and expand
ourselves and explore ourselves and
pickle ourselves and see the the spaces
there are to unleash and embody
foreign
so that's it and that's that and as
usual thanks for listening good
afternoon good evening
and good nights